Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 5, courbure.
Notre modèle mathématique est presque terminé.
À partir du tenseur métrique, qui permet
de mesurer des distances dans l'espace-temps,
nous savons prédire le mouvement d'un corps,
à l'aide des coordonnées, du vecteurs vitesse,
et de l'équation des géodésiques.
Mais la grande puissance de notre modèle
est qu'il ne fait aucune supposition quant
à la forme de la feuille, l'espace-temps.
Dans les vidéos précédentes, notre feuille
de papier était toujours représentée comme
un plan.
Mais rien ne nous empêche d’imaginer une
feuille de papier courbée, sur laquelle on
peut très bien définir des coordonnées,
et ainsi décrire le mouvement des objets.
L’espace-temps n’est pas toujours plat,
il peut présenter une géométrie courbée,
dont la courbure va entraîner des effets
étonnants sur les trajectoires des astres.
Si l’espace-temps est courbé comme une
sphère par exemple, deux géodésiques parallèles
partant de l’équateur vont se rapprocher
l’une de l’autre.
Plus communément, on appelle ce genre de
phénomène, la gravitation.
La courbure d’une surface est un concept
déterminant en relativité générale, et
il va nous falloir une définition précise
pour la décrire.
Imaginons un plan, quadrillé de façon régulière,
et une sphère, muni des coordonnées de latitude
et longitude.
Plaçons sur ces deux surfaces un même vecteur.
Dans les deux cas, on va transporter ce vecteur
vers le haut, puis vers la droite.
On obtient ainsi une nouvelle image du vecteur,
qui a été transporté sur la surface.
Maintenant, transportons le même vecteur,
jusqu’au même point, mais en le déplaçant
d’abord vers la droite, et ensuite vers
le haut.
Sur le plan, les deux images qu’on obtient
sont les mêmes.
L’ordre dans lequel on le déplace, d’abord
vers la droite, ou vers le haut, n’a pas
influencé l’image finale du vecteur.
Par contre, sur la sphère, les deux images
sont différentes, elles sont orientées différemment.
C’est cet effet qu’on appelle la courbure.
Certaines surfaces sont plates, l’image
du vecteur ne dépend pas du chemin qu’il
a suivi.
Et à l’inverse certaines surfaces sont
courbées, c’est à dire que le chemin que
va suivre le vecteur influence plus ou moins
son orientation finale.
Maintenant que l’on dispose d’une définition
précise pour la notion de courbure, on va
pouvoir mathématiser son concept.
Sur notre surface, choisissons l’un des
vecteurs de base.
Choisissons ensuite deux coordonnées, le
long desquelles on va déplacer le vecteur.
On peut choisir deux fois la même, mais également
deux coordonnées différentes.
On notera ces coordonnées mu, et nu.
Maintenant, déplaçons légèrement le vecteur,
d’une part le long des coordonnées mu puis
nu, et d’autre part le long des coordonnées
nu puis mu.
On obtient ainsi deux images du vecteur initial.
En effectuant la différence de ces deux images,
on obtient un vecteur qu’on appellera grand
R.
Si la surface est plate, sans courbure, grand
R est nul.
A l’inverse, plus la surface est courbée,
plus la longueur de ce vecteur différence
est grande.
Le vecteur R s’exprime comme la différence
entre deux vecteurs dérivés deux fois.
En effet, on a fait varier notre vecteur initial,
d’une part le long des coordonnées mu puis
nu, et d’autre part le long des coordonnées
nu, puis mu.
On a vu précédemment que les dérivées
des vecteurs de base se décomposent en des
symboles de Christoffel.
Après quelques remplacements, on obtient
une expression finale pour ce vecteur grand
R, dont on peut exprimer les composantes.
L’ensemble de tous ces nombres, toutes ces
composantes qui existent dans notre cas en
16 versions pour chaque combinaison de vecteurs
et de coordonnées, est ce qu’on appelle
le tenseur de courbure de Riemann.
Il caractérise entièrement la courbure d’une
surface.
Dès lors que l’on connaît le tenseur métrique,
on peut calculer les symboles de Christoffel,
et en déduire chaque composante de ce tenseur
de courbure.
Le tenseur de Riemann caractérise la courbure
d’une surface selon toutes les directions
possibles.
C’est l’outil le plus complet pour décrire
une géométrie.
Malheureusement, ses 16 composantes en font
un objet très lourd à manipuler.
En particulier, certaines de ces composantes
se répètent, et d’autres sont même nulles.
Pire encore, dans le cas d’un vrai espace-temps,
à 4 dimensions, le tenseur de courbure possède
256 composantes.
Pour simplifier cette description de la courbure,
nous allons construire deux outils plus performants,
à partir du tenseur de Riemann, qui vont
nous être plus agréables pour les calculs.
Le premier de ces deux outils, est ce qu’on
appelle le tenseur de Ricci.
Le tenseur de Ricci se présente comme un
tableau avec une ligne et une colonne pour
chacune de nos coordonnées.
Pour déterminer une composante du tenseur
de Ricci, par exemple sa composante 0,1, on
commence par se munir du tenseur de courbure.
Parmi toutes les composantes du tenseur de
courbure, on va sélectionner celles dont
les deuxième et quatrième indices correspondent
aux indices de la composante que l’on souhaite
calculer.
En l’occurence 0 et 1.
Parmi les composantes restantes, on sélectionne
à nouveau celles dont le premier et le troisième
indices sont les mêmes.
Pour finir, on effectue la somme des composantes
qui nous restent.
De façon intuitive, le tenseur de Ricci mesure
les variations de volume de la surface lorsqu’on
se déplace le long de sa courbure.
Sur une sphère par exemple, le volume que
renferment deux géodésiques parallèles
va diminuer au fur et à mesure qu’on progresse
sur la surface.
Les différentes composantes du tenseur de
Ricci mesurent ces variations de volume selon
les différentes directions de la surface.
Mais dans le cas de certaines géométries
régulières comme la sphère, la courbure
est la même dans toutes les directions, et
on va pouvoir la décrire par un seul nombre.
Ce nombre qui caractérise une moyenne de
la courbure selon toutes les directions, est
ce qu’on appelle la courbure scalaire.
Dans le cas où notre système de coordonnées
est orthogonal, avec des axes perpendiculaires
entre eux, cette courbure scalaire s’obtient
facilement, comme la somme de chaque composante
sur la diagonale du tenseur de Ricci, divisée
par la même composante du tenseur métrique.
Pour finir, illustrons ce concept de courbure,
par deux exemples concrets.
Le premier exemple est celui d’un espace-temps
vide, muni des coordonnées t, pour le temps
sur notre horloge, et x pour la position le
long d’un axe.
On a vu que cet espace-temps est décrit par
la métrique de Minkowski qui prend la forme
suivante.
Les composantes du tenseur métrique, dans
cet espace-temps vide, ne dépendent pas des
coordonnées, elles sont les mêmes partout
sur la grille.
Par conséquent leurs dérivées sont nulles,
ce qui implique que les symboles de Christoffel
valent tous 0.
Finalement, les tenseurs de Riemann, de Ricci,
et la courbure scalaire, valent donc tous
également 0.
L’espace-temps de Minkowski est plat, il
ne présente aucune courbure, et deux objets
qui se déplacent de façon parallèle ne
vont jamais se rencontrer.
Le deuxième exemple, est celui d’une sphère.
En un point de la sphère, que l’on décrit
par ses coordonnées de latitude et longitude,
le tenseur métrique prend la forme suivante.
Cette fois-ci, le tenseur métrique n’est
pas le même partout sur la sphère, il dépend
en particulier, de la coordonnée de latitude.
En calculant ses dérivées, on peut obtenir
l’expression des symboles de Christoffel.
Et à partir des symboles de Christoffel,
on peut calculer les différentes composantes
du tenseur de Riemann, puis du tenseur de
Ricci, et enfin la courbure scalaire.
A la surface d’une sphère, la courbure
scalaire est un nombre positif, ce qui signifie
que deux géodésiques parallèles ont tendance
à s’y rapprocher.
De plus, la courbure scalaire est d’autant
plus faible que le rayon de la sphère augmente.
Plus la sphère est grande, plus sa surface
est plate.